a Connecticut man charged with killing a
hotel worker in the Caribbean is
scheduled to appear in court this
morning
Scott Hapgood arrived back on the island
of Anguilla yesterday he's charged in
the death of Kenny Mitchell in April
Errol Barnett reports from Anguilla on
what can we expect at today's hearing
for second time this week Scott Hapgood
returned to Anguilla Wednesday with
security by his side local radio host DJ
hammer says the case has upset many on
the island the persons believe that mr.
Hapgood
was treated especially outraged has
escalated to threats against a 44
year-old and his family on Tuesday
hapgoods attorney blasted the decision
requiring her client to appear in person
it is cruel and unreasonable justice to
drag someone into the jurisdiction to
put them in harm's way on April 13th
Hapgood claims Mitchell an employee of
this luxury resort showed up at his
family's room with a knife demanding
money during a violent struggle Hopkins
family says he was bitten and stabbed
Mitchell who was beaten and suffocated
died shortly after a toxicology report
showing Mitchell had alcohol and cocaine
in his system no one close to Mitchell
living on the island agreed to appear on
camera CBS News has contacted a lawyer
representing Mitchell but has not heard
back Hapgood spoke exclusively with CBS
News on Monday I know that all I did was
defend my young daughters in front of an
attacker that was crazed and desperate
Errol Barnett for CBS this morning in
the capital of the British Caribbean
territory of Anguilla